Today, we're going to be talking about customer relationships.
In other words, how do you get, keep and grow customers.
So in the last lecture, you remember the business model canvas, all the 9 components of a startup.
We talked about value proposition, we talked about customer segments,
we talked about channels, but today we're going to focus on customer relationships.
Customer relationships really is about how do you get customers, how do you keep customers,
and how do you grow them.
Here are two get, keep and grow funnels, and the one thing to note is just the one on the top
represents a physical channel and the one on the bottom is web/mobile
and the thing to just remember is at physical channel is we're going to see later of the details
inside of how you get or acquire customers are different
than how you would acquire customers in web/mobile.
Just know that the physical representation of the customer's life cycle--get, keep and grow,
is kind of this double-barreled funnel and that's why we draw this way.
It just allows you to kind of understand how do customers get into our company,
how do we get them, how do we keep them, and how do we grow them.
And so let's look at both of these get, keep and grow for
physical and web/mobile channels in a little more detail.